Facebook page facebook.com slash book TV
Eric Larsen is next on book TV he talks
about the sinking of the Lusitania a
British ocean liner by a German u-boat
in 1915 and the influence of the event
on America's entry into World War one
you can't believe how excited people are
to see you I'm not kidding they came for
you and I don't think we could no other
author could have done this Eric so just
tell that to my daughters that they're
not impressed with you is that how that
goes so I want to talk about a little
bit about this idea of why we are so
intrigued by the idea of the doom ship
and here's my theory and you tell me
whether this fits what you're thinking
is it something about the adventure and
the optimism of the voyage colliding
with this tragedy that the passengers
don't know that they're sailing into is
it like the the collision of those ideas
no Tom all I know I you know I actually
I often wonder about that myself because
the thing that kind of drew me to the to
the Lusitania was the fact that I have
this maritime saying I think we all do
the Titanic and when I was a kid the
Flying Dutchman you know occupied much
of mine much in my imagination
but I think I think it's something I
think I think what what happens is I
think there's this something about the
idea of being way out in the middle of
the ocean and having something bad
happen to you and with no help available
that really that's at least what taps
into my mind brain yeah
plus consolation of it I think the
isolation and also the romance I mean
the idea of you know the glamour of a
crossing and then suddenly interrupted
by some catastrophe now for me I think
partly it's also because of my
Scandinavian Rubik now I should point
out that my roots actually do extent in
Minnesota and South Dakota but as you
you've won them over our problem you had
them at Scandinavians
there there are probably 300 Eric
Larson's but you know being being Skanda
David actually I don't know how my
forebears wound up landlocked but you
know we are you know seafaring people I
mean we before coming to you know Sioux
Falls we were killing from the sea that
kind of thing so oh you were that guy
where that guy yeah okay you know I'm
sure you you know something about the
wreck of the Edmund Fitzgerald yes this
kind I think this kind of defies your
theory because there was nothing all
that glamorous
it's an oar ship it's on Lake Superior
and yet it's something that anniversary
of the sinking is something that we
observe and we talk about every year
yeah but I don't find that particularly
romantic you don't no no I find that I
find that sinking a really an amazing
event I mean yeah well I'm the Great
Lakes and and you know from what I
understand Miura logically the Great
Lakes are terrible places to be and I
think incredible windstorm is the waves
just become something you don't even
experience on the ocean so that's to me
that's the fascinating part of the
Edmund Fitzgerald but my my my dark
fantasies tend toward the deep sea yeah
and speaking of the deep sea I'm sure
that when you were researching this you
were studying the underwater photos and
and video of the Lusitania wreck not
really really not why not every question
so far
thank you Eric that's how it's going to
go tonight
no no really here let me let me
elaborate on that because I did I did
rather late in the process take a look
at some of the undersea photography that
Robert Ballard had had done but his
thing I didn't want that to color my
impression during the course of my
research of what this voyage was like I
didn't want it to be you know this
rusting Hulk on the floor of the ocean
which is what it is now I wanted in my
mind this great glamorous ship with all
these great glamorous spaces and the
people walking aboard and so forth so
that's that's that's why I feel that way
that makes sense
I mean it's lying in three more than 300
feet of water right it's on its
starboard it's on its side and I don't
want to jump too far ahead here but it
sank very very quickly do you know why
it's lying in the position that it is
well I actually don't I can't tell you
for sure whether it's lying on the star
or port side and and I'm not sure in the
end that that had much to do with
exactly how how its sank when it's sank
what I do know is that when it sank for
much of that time and it was only 18
minutes it's incredible for much of that
time it was a 25 degree list so it may
well be that it's on the starboard side
but just before went under it's sort of
right of the cell because was so full of
water there was no imbalance then
plunged underneath so whether it wound
up on its poor starburst I can't tell
you I can't remember but it is sound of
sight how does how to set 18 minutes
sinking compare how unusual is that well
I mean it's incredibly unusual you don't
think about the Titanic the Titanic the
thing about the Titanic was that it was
actually a rather leisurely sinking but
there were not enough well if there were
Kanade wait i am not making light of the
sinking of Titanic I am saying that it
was at relatively speaking it was a
leisurely rate of sinking and you know
as you know the big issue with the
Titanic was that there were not enough
lifeboats now the issue with the
Lusitania was that there were more than
enough lifeboats more than enough
lifeboats they were 20 at the bore you
but there were 22 class-a lifeboats
which are the boats that you
traditionally think of when you think of
lifeboats but then they also had a lot
of collapsible boats which restored
underneath and that's how they made up
made up the difference the problem with
the Lusitania was the net result was
almost the same as the Titanic because
half the boats half the votes were
unusable because of this 25 degree list
if you can picture this you know the
boats on the port side once you try to
let those go they swung into the
superstructure those on the starboard
side when lowered to the rails as the
term we're suddenly out eight feet from
from the hull so if you can imagine
getting into one of these boats you're
already 60 feet above the sea and now
you got across this 8 foot span you know
and we're using deck chairs as ladders
and so forth one of my favorite little
vignettes is this little boy of course
it's a boy right takes a running leap
and jumps into the lifeboat you know but
anyway that's so that was the problem
with the Lusitania and then just the
fact that it sank so fast because of how
it was struck just since you've
mentioned the Titanic just to note that
there is a connection with the captain
of the Lusitania and the Titanic do I
remember that right no yeah no wasn't he
wasn't he being called to court the
connection is yeah yeah no no I bet that
you're thinking to him being a captain
at some point of it but know that there
is a very interesting connection with
the Titanic and that is that on the day
of just on the day before literally day
before departure which would departure
was on May 1 1915 captain Turner was
called to give testimony and a big
Titanic
[Music]
legal proceeding limitation of liability
proceeding in New York Kunik unit white
star line was trying to was trying to
limit its exposure to the various
lawsuits that resulted after the sinking
since the term limitation of Liability
hearing and Turner was called as an
expert witness to testify as to the
behavior of the Titanic and one of the
Titanic's captain and why he was going
so fast through ice and Turner did not
approve captain Turner knew that there
were risks to this crossing that he was
about to undertake and a lot of the
passengers knew that too well
aye aye captain Turner I don't I don't
I'm not not quite sure I agree with that
yeah I did they first let's deal with
the patches I think what we're talking
about here is that on May 1 a very same
thing happened in New York in the New
York newspapers that morning in the
shipping news pages which were widely
widely read the German embassy had
placed a an advertisement or actually
unnoticed let's say warning anybody who
was travelling on a passenger liner or
on any kind of merchant ship that when
they entered the waters around the
United Kingdom the so-called war zone
that Germany had declared back in
February this notice was essentially
reiterating that this war isn't existed
and if you sailed on a ship into those
waters you sailed at your own risk
now this ad did not name and did not
name the Lusitania but it was widely
interpreted to be aimed at the Lusitania
in part because like in the New York
world one of these notices appeared
right next to the ad for Kuhn or its
Lusitania so so that morning it was
probably some some you know cunning
advertising person said hey let's let's
give this but but so that was there was
that warning in the paper and you know
many people read it obviously some some
actually did not
we found out about the warning you know
after the ship was like you know a few
hours out which is a wonderful time to
find out that that the captain Turner
you know we know that he knew about the
warning but I don't think captain Turner
was all fazed by it I don't think he was
at all captain Turner was was a sailor
of the old school came up through the
great sailing ships he was a staunch guy
the kind of guy you know like when you
get on an airliner maybe I had to fly on
a panicky flyer so I look for all kinds
of cues as to what's going to happen so
I listen to the pilots voice you know I
don't know does anybody else do that
like so I listen for the you know it's
very cool and calm like you know okay
blah blah blah if I yes I heard Woody
Allen come over there what would you do
about me off that plane in a heartbeat
I'm telling you but no no so so so you
so but Turner Turner was the kind of guy
if you can kind of picture him you know
he was kind of guy who ran into him on
the deck he'd say yeah this is my gun
this is the kind of guy I want and he
was not at all
fazed by the potential of a submarine
attack I mean he had I think he firmly
believed that his ship was faster and
bigger than anything that any German
submarine could could tackle and that
that's something that's interesting to
hear you describe how few people really
understood how dangerous the German
submarine was right at that point you
know I have a note here but you note
that the author of Sherlock Holmes
actually got it right this is one of the
sort of fascinating little elements the
state to think that the thing it see how
I agree with you it's going to be good
from here on in no so the thing is
whenever you write when I when I write
history the way I like to write it one
very important thing is to is to try to
put yourself in the point of view of the
era and one thing that was very
important to grasp for me was how new
the submarine was in that time we are
all very familiar with it all
reward near run silent run deep ping
ping ping awesome there was by the way
no sonar in World War one there and
there were no depth charges until well
after the Lusitania episode but so so
the submarine was absolutely brand-new
and was not understood by by anybody as
to whether it would ever be a and a
couple of guys though got it one was
there Arthur Conan Doyle who before the
war wrote this really prescient short
story about an imaginary European
country called Norland which was clearly
meant to be Germany the imaginary
country that had a handful of submarines
and nonetheless managed to bring the
British Empire to its knees and that was
his story which ran some he wrote it
actually long before the war but it was
published in the month before the war
the other guy was Jackie Fisher the
Admiralty hierarchy in in Britain there
was the First Lord of the Admiralty and
that was Winston Churchill he was the
top dog in the Admiralty and then there
he was his number to a census the chief
operating officer of the Admiralty
Jackie Fisher who was the first C Lord
and he got it - he understood - he
understood that there were there was
certain characteristics of the design of
a submarine that virtually required that
it be used a certain way and Churchill
completely dismissed that he didn't he
didn't accept the idea that that a
submarine would ever be used against
civilian shipping it was it was just too
outrageous to contemplate but one of the
things that you note is the autonomy
that the submarines had once they were
at sea and you say once at sea a u-boat
captain was free to conduct his patrol
in whatever manner suited him without
supervision supervision from above what
did that really translate to what did
that mean well what that translated to
frankly was was extremely high-risk for
Germany that a mistake would be made and
the elephant in the room America
wouldn't climb into the war with guns
blazing you know what it meant was that
when you were the captain of a submarine
typically where you were young men you
know late 20s early 30s a crew of about
36 once you got out of range of German
transmitters you were literally on your
own you can make any decisions you want
if you saw a worthy target you didn't
have to call back to to headquarters you
just you just went for it and so the
autonomy was both was both thrilling for
these guys but also a huge huge
responsibility and and I wonder how
important it is to understand how
captain Shaw Schweiger is that the
warrior serve eager how it is to
understand how he interpreted that
autonomy well I mean sugar you know took
it and ran with it he was one of the one
of the one of the main sub one of the
big submarine aces even early in the war
he was a very talented a very talented
hunter of ships using his submarine he
was however when I went into this I was
thinking okay I kind of knew that there
was going to be this collision course
thing between the the submarine and the
Lusitania because the captain of this
ship the captain of the submarine as it
all submarine captains had kept a
meticulous war log detailing everything
that happened for the moment he left
Germany to the time he returned so I
knew all of all that and and it made an
obvious narrative thing to have the
Lusitania and the submarine converging
but in the course of researching this I
came across all this interesting
information about Shri girl I mean I
wanted him to be this classic villain
that's going into it I wanted yeah okay
I would love a monocle you know you know
I I love I love a monocle like a scar
you know that kind of thing and what I
got was this nice guy in 30 year old guy
handsome you know charismatic beloved by
his crew well-liked throughout the
submarine service and
one of his friends a fellow submarine
commander said of him at one point so
you know he couldn't hurt a fly
he couldn't hurt a fly after the war you
know so so it's just yeah I've opened
the book to this room forty cadence and
this is it is this the positioning this
is the report on the position yeah one
of the remarkable things about the the
story went as I started getting into
reading about I was having that I gotta
say I was not I came to the Lusitania
sort of reluctantly yeah I had like
nothing else on my plate but I had this
maritime tic you know and and I was just
interested in the Lusitania and I don't
know I started reading about it and I
started getting more and then I did have
my first like exploratory archival trip
and that's what really sort of cemented
it but but one of the things that really
surprised me was the the role of this
super secret operation within the
Admiralty called room 40 row 40 was
established very early in the war to
take advantage of three nearly
miraculous events that had occurred
which was on three different occasions
again very early in the war the British
came into possession of Germany's three
main code books governing almost all of
their wireless transmissions both naval
and diplomatic and so that the subshell
and a handful of others got together and
formed room for tea which was to take
advantage of these captured code books
and use them to read Wireless messages
intercepted from the German Navy and
they became very very adept at this and
one of the mysteries when I'm in history
one of the most interesting things about
the saga is that you 20 the submarine
wireless message and receive wireless
messages and so from the very beginning
this room room 40 knew exactly what the
submarines orders were knew exactly
where it was supposed to end up on
patrol and during its first this is what
you're looking at during its first 24
hours at sea its wireless operator
sent 14 physician reports which the
British in room 40 duly intercepted and
decoded so they knew exactly where the
submarine was for the first 24 hours so
that's the chapter you're looking at
yeah I mean in the book it's at 2:00
a.m. the exact location 4:00 a.m. 6:00
a.m. run 8:00 a.m. and then you say the
report sees where was all this
information for you to find it it's all
in the intercept in the United National
Archives of the United Kingdom they have
delighted to find these vast caches of
information they have all the decoded
intercepts we are all all there and
they're in their files just really
really tremendous stuff is it the thing
about also about German submarine
commanders with it was that they were
they were said to be quote unquote
garrulous that has to defend us to say
they liked using their wireless they
like chatting over the over they did
they like chatting over the wireless and
partly I mean I have to I have to thank
the part of it might it might be because
they knew that ultimately they were
going to be dealing with this is this
amazing loneliness and so it was kind of
comforting to be able to say but they
had no clue that that somebody was
listening and no idea and not only they
had no idea then they had no idea
through most of the war German Navy was
so arrogant as to believe that their
codes would never be broken it's just
extraordinary how hard was that code to
break what kind of information did you
well well I did a code I mean once you
have the codebook no yeah but no but but
it there are two elements to this is a
codebook which is key and that consists
of essentially three letter groups
including a three-letter group four of
all things Nantucket which sort of
suggests a certain aspiration you know
on the part of the German Navy but the
code when the Germans put their messages
in code used the codebook primarily as
the first step and then they would
further scrambling using a cipher so
there was a lot of code breaking that
did have to go on even though they not
code breaking but deciphering there's a
difference in cryptographic circles you
know so but but but it was relatively
easy to break that cipher because
how regimented the German Navy was in
communications with its ships I don't
want to bore anybody with the details of
this but essentially if you signal the
same light ship every night at 6:00 p.m.
you're going to eventually catch on that
this is the light ship and at 6:00 p.m.
and this message and you know what it's
saying
so they through that process they were
able to become very adept not only at
deciphering but of course using the
codebook to break the codes I had
someone in the audience earlier before
we started asking me about how you
discovered the level of detail even
about what the passengers of the
Lusitania were wearing the the flour
that somebody wore in their pocket or
something like that where is all that
information to be found I hate to say it
but all that detail is in the very
detailed cataloging personal effects
found on the dead afterwards and who did
all that cataloging it was the mostly
the British Navy people in Queenstown
Ireland some QAR people they're cute I'd
actually put out a confidential book
after the sinking which contained just
every every name every body every list
the specialist special effects every
list of personal effects and the reason
it did this that we can they listed all
the personal effects because because
they hoped that for all these
unidentified bodies is something
something might trigger is somebody's
recollection and say oh maybe that's
aunt Maude you know that kind of thing
but that's where all those things you're
listening to author Eric Larson at the
Fitzgerald theater his new book is
called dead wake the last crossing of
the Lusitania
it's a thread event at the Fitz and you
can follow the thread at the thread NPR
on Twitter so let's place these two
adversaries the Lusitania and the u-boat
on the collision course the Lusitania
has been at sea for six days
licinia set sail set sail you know set
out on on May 1 and the the the
torpedoing occurred on May 7 okay yeah
and the submarine set out on April
surgery so what has happened on the
voyage of the Lusitania leading up to
that a lot of flirting a lot of lot of
lot of shuffleboard they actually did
play shuffleboard you know you know the
the voyage until Thursday May 6th was
really pretty much uneventful and
actually was probably getting fairly
tedious you know I don't know how many
people have been on transatlantic
voyages that actually for the research
my wife and I did you did we did a
voyage on the Queen Mary - it's an
amazing chef Wow and we set out in in
November after Thanksgiving this was
fairly midway through the research and
did the cross and of course you know
sooner that we leave New York Harbor
that we're in a forced 10 Gale you know
that spoke to me in my Scandinavian
heart but but and actually in fact the
Queen Mary - is a very stable ship even
and even an incredibly foul weather but
one of the things that really came home
to me on this voyage is that you know
after you leave the harbor
it's boring really fast you know and and
when it comes down to is what you do is
you sort of live from meal to meal you
know and the same thing was happening on
the ship meals were everything you know
you sit sit at your tables and these
fancy Dining's in first-class even the
third-class was supposed to be really
quite quite good and quite lush and very
you know very very good so they wanted
to attract the immigrant trade and so
you had so you had all this kind of cool
shipboard stuff and people were writing
about that survivors you know had left
stories about what was happening so it
was very good but you're crossing did
give you that sense of what it's like to
be without sight of land right in that
isolation so did it so did and by the
way the captain was very very very
particular that this was not a cruise
this was a voyage a voyage he was very
very proud
well very proud of the fact that the
Queen Mary 2 is a point-to-point vessel
it does not stop in the Caribbean
you know I placed the place and you know
but it's it's a really it's really this
amazing ship that does the the
transatlantic thing was built to deal
with everything that the Atlantic has to
has to has to offer and and but the
thing is that when you're out in the
middle of the ocean there really is that
feel even today you know when you're way
out there and you look at your you know
every day you can plot you can see where
you are on the on the on the course
yeah something catastrophic were to
happen and something catastrophic could
happen could strike another ship and the
fog could you know some some who knows
what but but you're alone and nobody can
get to you not for hours and hours you
know and that's that's really sobering
and but the most sobering thing is that
now is this what not enforcement the
case with the Lusitania but today when
you're on a ship like that before you
before the ship even leaves the wharf
you are required to put on your life
jacket strap it on fit it Wow and then
you take it off and I am here to tell
you that it gets your attention when you
put that life jacket on you realize whoa
this is real now unfortunately that was
not the case of Lusitania did did not
make him try it on I mean did you have
that moment where you thought would I
have the presence of mind to know what
to do if you know something happened to
the ship what you mean by crossing yeah
yeah yeah I'm it's like what would I do
right and and of course in the context
of all the research that I've done on
the Lusitania I think okay what do I
jump in know do I do not try to get into
a lifeboat yes no and do I hope that
they launch them better than the
Lusitania yes you know so I did I really
really thought about it and then I
really also see you sort of finding this
just me I guess I sort of found myself
periodically this is after of course
leaving that leaving the gale but
walking along
I can looking out and just trying to
imagine torpedo coming right toward the
ship you know what would that have been
like you know because it it comes you
know if there's only at the torpedo I
know I can't remember what it was like
35 or 45 miles an hour which is not it's
not super fast you know what I think you
said 44 years 42 something bad so it's
thanks thank you so what is anytime here
it is right here my point being that
that that when you're when you're
standing there you know you you can see
this thing coming because of the
compressed air exhaust and it forms a
very clear track on the surface of the
sea and you would see this thing coming
towards you and it's like just really
kind of revelatory to me it's like my
god what you know you're you're helpless
you know there really not only you can
do like that Steve Martin routine
worries with it the is marketing the
product it's like a it's like a airline
collision detector gives you a 20-second
warning yeah so you know 20 seconds
before everybody else so what right okay
so the Lusitania has been at sea six
days what's happening underwater on the
u-boat it's getting ever closer right
under under under water and first of all
one very important point to make
shraeger captains figure was not
stalking the Lusitania he was not
hunting for the Lusitania his orders
were to look for large troop transports
that were leaving from sort of an
unusual part of Britain ordinary that
the troop ships left from one side of
the channel crossing to the other but
these German intelligence had picked up
word that there would be these troop
transports leaving from unaccustom'd
ports among them Liverpool on the
western coast of Britain of England and
Ireland and that though they were going
to be doing that because the German
naval German intelligence had come to
believe that Britain might be planning
an amphibious landings and fibia s--
invasion
of Germany through the north state from
the North Sea coast so his orders were
to look for these large troop transports
his Patrol was just a misery of foul
weather of zero targets of one stretch
being hunted by a patrol line of three
destroyers that very nearly would have
had very serious consequences if the
Patrol him if the destroyers had kept up
their their pursuit just a little bit
longer and he was having a horrible
horrible time I'd actually heard from
some readers who find themselves rooting
for captain Schneider serega now I'm not
saying that that's a copy effect but
plus the conditions and this are all
Sarila 30 Harriman 36 men in in a metal
tube note one lavatory and and and you
know they and you know the smell of
day-old onions and everything else and
guys 36 guys who wear their leather sea
suits day-in day-out because what's the
point of changing you know the swash
figurehead weapon also carried them
aboard his summer here and we had one
point six dachshunds and that really
humanized him for me dogs did it so as a
former former dog owner I'm just
thinking about okay poop scoop are you
how do you deal with but on the other
hand you're living with 36 guys and
leather it's it's not it it's probably
not relevant but the way the weight came
about with the dachshunds is that is
that you had you had he had one dogs on
the board and then torpedo his ship and
and sank and then the crew spotted this
other dachshund that was in a box
floating in the water they rescued the
dachshund royal aboard the dachshund was
so sweet named Maria because the ship
had had Maria in the name little
hanky-panky
and then suddenly sudden suddenly for
puppy
what's up he's on the submarine you know
and so at one point had six dachshunds
aboard the sea we have to talk about the
cargo though before I wanted to make
sure I asked you about this so you say
that the Lusitania is problematic but
entirely legal under US neutrality laws
the Lusitania was carrying 50 barrels 94
cases of aluminum powder 50 cases of
bronze powder what for well who knows
what that was for
possibly and those don't really qualify
as munitions they qualify more as
ingredients potentially for missions
models for many many other things but
those aren't even the juiciest right and
then they artillery well the the sort of
quasi inert shrapnel shells in other
words these were not they did not in
fact it sounds scary but they do not in
fact pose much danger of explosion and
the cartridges that held that yes and
what and then it carry carried tons and
tons and tons of small-arms ammunition
which is also not any sort of threat to
the ship because it was not known small
arms ammunition was not known to explode
on mass if it caught fire would sort of
cook off as they say
so what nonetheless these things were
all it is this is one of the things
there was no mystery there were in fact
munitions aboard the Lusitania they were
listed quite openly on this manifest
this cargo manifest
and it has there been controversy though
about the fact that the ship was
carrying what could potentially be seen
as arms and yes that's been one of the
lingering kind of issues about the
Lusitania but what but it's typically
been in the context of like like was it
the munitions that sank the Lusitania
and the answer to that is no it was not
that's that's really pretty clear now to
any serious student of the Lusitania but
one lingering conspiracy theory is that
there was a there were caches maybe of
of explosives that we have been smuggled
aboard disguised as furs or oysters or
something and you know what there may
have been there may have been I can't
say for sure that there weren't but what
I can say with with 95% certainty as
that is not what sank to ship okay so
we've got the u-boat and they're not
hunting specifically rock hunter but it
was the Lusitania comes into view
essentially how does that happen is it
is one of the one of the many just
really strange things that had to come
together for this this incident to
happen you know there was so many
bizarre bizarre moments bizarre the
range of forces that all had to come
together at exactly the right time and
place that caused the sinking is a
remarkable one of which is as the
Lusitania is in the Irish Sea it is
completely socked in with with fog which
is good for the Lusitania because fog
was a protection against submarines it's
not so good for speaker who has his sick
to death of fog at this point he's had
fog about the entire voyage he comes up
again to periscope that takes a look
he's like there's just nothing totally
socked him goes back down and goes back
down deep because you know he doesn't
want to get run over by a ship in these
what I referred to as the the Western
Approaches this is the because were the
main sea routes into the Irish Sea
toward Liverpool and so forth so you
have this fog right Lusitania doesn't
see big area doesn't see Lusitania he
has had such a miserable voyage
miserable patrol that he at this point
has made a decision to actually turn
around and go home he's decided to go
home so he turns around decides to go
home goes up to check the weather
miraculously the fog is gone not only is
the fog gone
the day that is left behind is one of
the most beautiful days anybody can
possibly remember the sea is like glass
it's warm sunny there's there's no wind
it's just the one of the most gorgeous
days you could possibly imagine and
through this periscope he sees this
forest of what he describes in his war
logs forest of masts and and and
smokestacks and he thinks at first that
it's it's several ships and as he
watches this ship makes a turn that
immediately puts it out of his out of
his reach he's very he's really pissed
off he starts cursing he tells a friend
later he just unleashes a torrent of
profanity but he decides that he's going
to follow just in case just in case and
then miraculously sort of a dark miracle
captain Turner on the on the Lusitania
orders another turn which puts it right
in the perfect sweet spot for the
submarine isn't the Lusitania alerted
that there is a submarine active off the
south coast of Ireland the messages that
the Lusitania receive this is a point of
real really interesting controversy the
messages that captain Turner received by
way of warning will very generic
messages you know like submarines active
off south coast of Ireland well okay
that's a that's a pretty big swath of
water
I'd also said plural by the way
submarines and but in fact there was so
much more information available for the
warnings that could have been sent to
Turner and this is this is a very
important point because Sri gear finally
now that the weather has improved starts
getting really lucky and sinks three
ships in short order Turner has never
told about those sinking well never told
I nobody knows never told about those
things moreover he has also never told
that u-20 is for certain in the vicinity
and that u-20 has a patrol it has been
assigned to patrol zone right off
Liverpool right in the path of all the
Cunard vessels and and and none of the
documentation reveals why was why there
was a specific decision or none at all
about not yeah there's what what there
is is is a really startling absence of
information in in the archives about
what specifically happened in terms of
messages that should have been or should
not have been sent all we know is what
was sent we also know that the the
chairman of Kuhn art Allen booth on the
morning when you know the newspapers the
newspapers had the news of the sinking
of these these shifts by u-20 and he was
Allen poor Allen Boothe was in Liverpool
and having breakfast and reading the
paper and he sees these in paper and he
suddenly he he stops eating breakfast
gets up and goes right to the right to
the chief naval officer and in in
Liverpool and says look we need to send
a really direct message to to to Turner
because look at this you know and once
again this a vague message was sent to
Turner you know and so at this point
poor Turner he's hearing that he's
hearing that there are submarines again
very gentle warnings submarines ahead of
him plural submarines behind him plural
and it's like this is a situation he was
never trained for you know he was never
in a situation to anticipate or a
planner or plot a course for this kind
of a this kind of a circumstance have
you thought about what he could have
done even if he had been alerted to the
presence of these submarines well I I
think well what could have and frankly
should have happened and again this is
that we're now talking you know I mean I
don't say this in the book that this
should or should have happened but you
know what what what could have been done
is first we could have been given much
more specific information which might
have really gotten his attention which
certainly would have gotten mine and you
know he could have been diverted into
Queenstown
now rename Cove
he could've been diverted into
Queenstown which is where Lisbon in fact
in the past had had stopped for on male
runs until they realized that there were
just too many incidents of scraping the
bottom and the Shell Harbor there he
could have been diverted there there was
a safe a new and safer route that had
just been opened at the so called
northern route which he could have been
diverted to take and he could have been
escorted by the stories because several
destroyers were in fact available and in
fact the Lusitania and other Cunard
ships had had been well not to listen
area but other kinships had been
escorted in the past okay so that's one
of the really important lingering
questions is why why was it left so so
alone and and you have not been able to
draw any specific conclusion what did
you just know there's no smoking memo
you know from from Churchill or anybody
in the ambulance a hey let's leave this
this ship in harm's way there's nothing
like that what there is though is a body
of evidence that if you know bits and
pieces and things and that if you look
at it and you work let's say you're in a
court of law and you tried to use that
evidence to prove beyond a shadow of a
doubt that the Admiralty wanted the
Lusitania in harm's way to get America
into the war you couldn't prove it at
the same time if you take the same body
of evidence used to turn it around and
usually but I think scientists referred
to as the null hypothesis approach tried
to use the same evidence to disprove
that there was some kind of conspiracy
you can't do that either this is too
much stuff and what what I do what I do
taking the cowardly approach I hang it I
hang on a particular naval historian
british naval historian and the former
actually intelligence guy initially when
he wrote a book about room for daeun was
talking about the Lusitania he said that
in his view was a monumental cock-up as
he put it a mistake it was a mistake but
later in life as the more and more
evidence came before and this is
something that he says in an interview
that is
in the files at the Imperial War Museum
in London which is a great place yes
agree and yeah really really terrific
and in this interview he has he
expresses a change of heart and he says
he says you know I'm a lover of the
Royal Navy and you know but he says that
there's just so much evidence that he is
he has changed his mind it has come to
believe at this point that there was a
plot of some kind but he doesn't know
what you know where the plot originated
what kind of detail the plot and Bobby
just felt that it was a plot that was
and then he says if anybody else can
explain it in a different way please
step forward and do so because it's very
hard to to successfully do that and the
motivation of the plot if there was one
would have been if there was what the
United day event that's clear that the
motivation would have been that that
possibly American might have entered the
war that and but and one thing is very
clear by the way is that is that
Churchill wanted America to enter the
war and actually in an earlier letter it
says as much he says he's talking to the
board of the head of the Board of Trade
and then Runciman he's talking to him in
a letter and he says you know we need
the traffic from America you know as
much of it as we can and then he has
this very interesting line he says and
if some of it gets in trouble all the
better
hmm the plot thickens rings with no real
conclusion roads you mentioned earlier
that you stood on the at the rails at
the on the deck of the queue II was at
the tree - yeah and you imagine what it
might have been like to see that tornado
or torpedo come with come towards you
tornadoes that is what happened isn't it
weren't there
passengers who actually saw the torpedo
approached that that is one of the most
spectacular things that I came well I
came across in the various many many
statements by survivors by the way exist
in terms of depositions testimony and
personal accounts and and what comes
through was most clearly about that
particular moment for
I recall it this beautiful day beautiful
day and everybody's thinking ok we're
home safe you know they're like 14 hours
from from you know from Liverpool
everybody's thinking you know one woman
actually expresses she says so where is
this danger that we were all warned
about you know and everybody in the
first class is just finished lunch the
second class lunch seating has just
begun kids are jumping rope upstairs the
crew is getting luggage up on deck
everything's cool you know people are
hanging out on the rails just looking at
the beautiful beautiful sea suddenly
this is versus a bubble of air which is
the the first the first as the submarine
as the torpedo was leaving the
submarines torpedo tube and then you see
the track this compressed air track
moving across this absolutely glassine
sea you know and people standing at the
rail saw this and one one guys getting
there and a woman came up to him and
said is that it's not a torpedo and he
can't answer because he says he says he
says he's just sick at heart one guy
this is this is what I love about the
whole you know like from 89 to 1920s
this is this irrepressible thing about
people one guy one guy runs to the rail
to watch to watch this torpedo hit you
know further down the hall obviously and
and he says later he says in his account
he says he says it was beautiful
the most beautiful sight this torpedo
moving you know and he could actually
see the torpedo ten feet below the
surface the sea was so still and clear
you can see the torpedo and then of
course because the because the way in
vents the compressed air the track is
actually back up here so it's like this
fish surging through them through the
see it you say as the torpedo advanced
the water rushing past its nosed turned
a small propeller which unscrewed a
safety device that prevented detonation
during storage then what happens once
the welder is approaching yeah then
torpedo yeah
at tornadoes on my mind sharknado well
what happens then is that a zit of
course as progressing then it's been
then and then it is it is it is armed
when it makes contact with the hull
essentially a charges fire the the
larger charge three and fifty pounds of
TNT and hex a night explodes against the
hull in a very very very characteristic
signature by the way sort of a tall
geyser of de briefs because of the the
physics of how these things explode
against a hall and yeah so that's that
was how the the explosion occurred you
have this is that I think this is what
is incredible what bigger writes about
the the torpedo striking home right what
it's do you want to read it you don't do
what you want do you want to read I
really I take it point to because you
know yeah it's right there okay so so so
I wish I'd just read this hold yeah sure
so strigas I just read this thing to you
here's figures log entry for to 10:00
p.m. a7 began with the word trust for
impact he wrote quote torpedo hits
starboard side close behind the bridge
and unusually great detonation follows
with a very strong explosive cloud cloud
reaches far beyond the forward funnel
the explosion of the torpedo must have
been accompanied by a second one boiler
or coal or powder I mean that's very
terse and but very descriptive and thank
God you wrote it
I mean this stuff as goal as a writer
and now I have you have honestly if you
have this war log was like oh my gosh I
can work with this
you know so yeah what what tell me about
opening that log and reading through and
flipping through to find that moment
well I I mean I read the entire log from
from mom you know from day one to the
end and it was all all fascinating in
some ways the some ways the launch and
the impact were almost anticlimactic did
you get that sent yeah because you know
there were all these other things were
happening on on the way but but what was
so useful about that was that it allowed
me to sort of the whole reason I did
this book is because I wanted it to be I
saw an opportunity that I had not
existed from the past books to put on my
offered Hitchcock hat and make this kind
of an exercise in nonfiction suspense
yeah and the log was really pivotal for
that crucial for that because you know
that's the essence of suspense knowing
where this guy is exactly and what he's
doing what he's thinking what's
happening to him and then knowing where
the Lusitania is and what they're doing
and what's happening with them and this
knowing as we know that they're on a
convergence course although they don't
know it you know it's it's very very
powerful you know I'm kind of surprised
to hear you say that about the suspense
because I thought there was a lot of
suspense and devil in the White City
well thank you I didn't you
yeah but different kind of support yes
then a different magnitude I think a
different intensity of suspense yes I
get you yeah I think so the the SOS
telegram from the Lusitania reads we
think we are off Kinsale is that right
late position ten miles off Kinsale come
at once bit list later please come with
all haste no what what are they saying
well and that's actually big list later
big list later but I always make this
bed because
has was referred to as the advanced
readers copy LARC which by the way has
been heavily corrected okay but yeah big
list later so what was your question I
what what are they saying I mean what
are they communicating so what they're
communicating is that you know they've
been hit by the by the by the by the
torpedo what time do I have on that on
that telegram I don't yeah I didn't know
that I'll find it what's happening at
this point is the ship has taken on this
amazing list in a very very short time
it's pretty clear at this point that the
ship is foundering and everybody frankly
is stunned that that this is even
happening that this gigantic ship you
know one torpedo and you know this is
just really minutes after the impact and
so that was that was the message that
that went out this big list and sent
help at once and then what happens as
they're trying to send help well what
happens the way the the way the ship the
way the ship sank is so much because the
torpedo hit just exactly the sweet spot
in the hall and frankly hip was not even
the spot that Jeter was aiming for this
is one of those other things was an
accident
he had miscalculated the Lusitania speed
so it hit a place he did not intend to
hit the place of hit happened to me the
perfect spot for various reasons one it
it killed virtually half the crew
because they were all in the luggage
hold getting the luggage together and
there was a shift change and exactly
that moment this torpedo destroys that
part of the ship it also had a place
where the flooding of these so called
longitudinal coal bunkers which are now
mostly empty because the ship was mostly
dumped at the voyage flooded those coal
bunkers flooded the front forward bunker
water was surging into into the boiler
rooms
the second so-called second explosion
which essentially knocked out the steam
steam system the steam distribution
system lost all control of the engine so
they couldn't a they couldn't stop the
ship the engines were the brakes
we're still progressing at 18 knots so
not only do you have flooding you had
forced flooding which is water coming in
at an incredible rate and that's why the
ship was suddenly suddenly listing and
so here you have the situation where you
know all this has happened really really
fast really fast as I said 18 minutes
before the thing disappeared from view
um there's a wonderful detail here you
say in this paragraph it's now 2:20 p.m.
10 minutes since the torpedo struck and
you're talking about deckhands and
passengers are waiting for the ship to
slow to allow the launching of the bow
run and examine which is a very
important important point another again
the ship is still moving right after the
Tokyo at 18 knots it's gradually slowing
the reason the reason the whole the
reason it's important to know that the
engines were no longer working is
because you can't stop the ship and if
the ship isn't stopped you can't launch
the lifeboats
you'd be lethal to launch I mean when
it's going at a very very low rate they
are trained actually for certain
launching procedures but at 18 knots to
launch a boat suicide then you have the
junior third officer who says a strange
silence prevailed and small
insignificant sounds such as the whimper
of a child the cry of a seagull or the
bang of a door assumed alarming
proportion right you read his oh yeah
his diary speed what he this is a
statement that he left that's
extraordinary secretive it is as
recently as 2012 a British Commission
issued a report to say that the British
weren't to blame for the fast sinking of
the ship and the loss of what this is
really haunted the UK oh yeah sure sure
it really has it has you know well it's
funny there was a there was a there that
I came across an interesting document
that was done after some revelations in
the 1960s or some well they were
revelations but there was something
discredited but the Admiralty
even then had done a detailed had asked
for the historical section of the
Admiralty to do a really detailed look
at this book in the various charges and
you know dispelled most of what it came
up with but but in the end nothing it
was true that in the end the guy rags he
says says in conclusion I say let
sleeping dogs lie let's not respond but
yes it's still it's still to this day is
something that is kind of funny but and
really and really it's because people
get an idea locking their hands about
conspiracy and so forth that the second
explosion and all this stuff and and
really what is tends to be overlooked is
like in the last less decade or so two
really excellent forensic engineering
studies were done on the Lusitania of
the Lusitania both came to the same
conclusion independently that it was a
disruption of the steam distribution
system probably the the the main steam
distribution line that failed because of
you know contact most likely with water
and which interestingly is exactly what
captain Turner concluded moments after
after that second second exploration one
last question before I go out to the
audience then we'll take some audience
questions you write about findings of
those photographs of the recovered
bodies where are they yeah these are
these are right after the right after
the the sinking of course bodies were
recovered and bodies began coming coming
ashore floating ashore they were stored
in they were housed in three makeshift
morgues in Queenstown and in order to
assure that there was a record of the
bodies they were all photographed before
being buried in a you know in a mass
grave now I knew these photographs
existed and when I was in Liverpool at
the University of Liverpool which holds
the historical qunit archives I asked
about them
and and they say well we have them but
we're not going to let you see them
because nobody we don't let anybody see
them anymore and so I fine did some more
work there then I asked him again I said
well yeah could you ask somebody higher
up maybe to see if I could you know and
so the next day I come in and they say
well we're going to let you look at
those photographs and I said well what
caused the change of heart you said well
the senior archivist loved devil in the
White City so but these were very I have
to have to say that these were they
would not let me bring my digital camera
in which is the way you do research
these days you photograph documents you
don't Xerox them anymore or photocopy
them sitting there looking at these
these photographs was actually really
very powerful and moving and very
important because it told me that that
this is what the story is about it's not
about the conspiracy theories it's not
about all that stuff it's not about the
geopolitics involved it's about the fact
that this was first and foremost a
tragedy a human tragedy of great
dimension and here with these people men
women and children and these photographs
dressed you know perfectly wearing
exactly what they were wearing at lunch
you know that day and looking frankly
like they could walk out of those
photographs it's beautiful high silver
content black-and-white photographs
looking like they could just walk out of
these these photographs and you know
walk onto the stage right here it is
very powerful thank you for an
interesting conversation thank you for a
very interesting interview thank you
[Music]
okay questions from the yes sir yes I'll
hold a microphone thank you well once
again you have not accompanied the book
with photographs and maybe you want to
speak to that again sure sure so he says
once again I have not accompany the book
with with photographs all my other books
have photographs just not a lot you know
it's a thing with me and I'll explain it
my feeling about what I do a book is is
that what it looked like this my goal is
to create as rich historical experience
for the reader as I possibly can I want
the reader to sink into the past and and
then emerge at the end of having read
maybe even in one sitting my honor to
settings--
emerge with a sense of having lived in
that past time photographs in a
nonfiction book III totally embrace a
philosophy put forward by a in this case
he writes novels but I've adapted this
to nonfiction John Gardner in a book
called on becoming a novelist he says
that you know his job a novelist job is
to create the fictional dream now my job
is to create the non-fiction dream but
the novelist job is to create the
fictional dream and anything that takes
you away from that dream is to be
avoided whether it's fancy language
whether it's bad punctuation lousy
grammar
you know italics anything that takes you
away from the dreams is a bad bad thing
you know some of you some of you don't
like italics either is that I don't like
I dog so so so my feeling about
photographs is that you know first of
the reproduction is terrible in a trade
nonfiction book second the photographs
tend to be inserted in the form of
what's referred to as a signature a
glossy signature and I get stuck into
the book sometimes maybe there are even
two of these signatures and you know
it's like a lighthouse beacon you're
sitting there reading this book and the
temptation to go to this glossy thing
and look for photographs this is
- great and every time you leave the
story frankly I think I think it's an
opportunity for you to leave the book
altogether and I want to avoid that so
this time I actually got my way mainly
maybe because my new editor is brilliant
she felt the same way and if you think
about night to remember had no
photographs rise and fall of the Third
Reich had no photographs harush to my
head no photographs the Bible had no
photographs me you know anyway right
over on that side hi
I noticed that your your books your
stories tend to have a lot of death in
them are you drawn to that aspect or is
it just kind of a byproduct of the
amazing thing that happened made you
want to death you know I mean it's what
makes things compelling is you know it
you know tragedy and disaster and so
forth I mean you know if I was to write
about you know Churchill's walk through
a Hyde Park on a Sunday morning I mean
you know it's lovely but nobody's going
to read it it's it's it's just where the
stories are the stories I'm not drawn to
it I'm not I'm not looking to tell dark
stories it's not like I'm hunting notice
this is too too cheery I'm going to go
do this think you know it's just what
happens you know it's it's yeah I just
world's fair wasn't that dark question
right over here so I know you talked
about doing the Lusitania because you
didn't have anything else to do but both
the devil no I City and thunderstruck
and then this one do you have a
particular affinity to the late 1800s
Early 1900s that kind of draws you that
is for see that is for sure
yeah I love the period from 1890 to
about 1920 now in the garden the beast
was a little bit outside that but I
loved that for for other reasons
Martha Hart throne but I love that I
love that period because there was
something and first why I do tend to
write about American subjects because
human life
my audience is American and it's where
my territory and the thing about that
1890 to 1920 period is that it was when
America was just was a different place
which is fused with this hubris and and
optimism and overconfidence and whenever
you have hubris and optimism and
overcome confidence you've got great
stories and and dark stories as well so
yeah so that I do love that period
another small thing about that period
and this is actually it's not a small
thing it's actually very important is
that it was also the heyday of the
typewriter it's very important because
you can go nuts reading correspondence
and when it's all in type type type
reports typewriters and it's just it's
like it's like heaven you know in devil
in White City my favorite character was
Olmstead but but the man had abysmal
handwriting and and I mean one day I was
in my office this is when I was living
full-time in Seattle and I was and my
wife came into my office and I have my
head down on the desk and my magnifying
glass right next to me just what's wrong
is it old stay anyway yeah question
right over there where oh yeah yeah I'm
just wondering if you can talk a little
bit about um the details you included
with President Wilson in this book and
kind of why you decided to include that
dimension sure okay so President Wilson
I really came to have a whole new
appreciation for President Wilson from
this book because I considered him kind
of a prim and proper stiff you know
before I had no interest in him but as I
was researching as I doing my research
in the Library of Congress and I was
going through Wilson's papers in
particular for the period around the
Lusitania I came across his love letters
to his girlfriend now Wilson in August
of 1914 lost his wife of many years you
know really about the same time that the
war grew up in Europe and he was crushed
by by grief and loneliness and and
really really was affected by it and
then in 1915 he meets and falls
head-over-heels in love
with this woman Nita bowling golf a
40-something Widow in Washington DC who
most often seen tooling around town in
her electric car and so he falls still
in love with her and she's kind of
holding back a little bit and he's
writing these really passionate love
which I came across in the Library of
Congress I'm reading these things dozens
of these love letters dozens of the most
passionate outpourings is like
afterwards I wanted the light of
cigarette I mean was like my god and and
so so at that point I just I just said I
don't care these are going in you know
this is going to be part of the story
and and you know context is crucial
Wilson is a very important player
obviously the whole saga and trying to
get into his where he was in his mind
during that period when the ship was
making its it's making the crossing the
last crossing and coincidentally did a
lot of these really important letters
were written during that week you know
before the leading up to the to the
sinking so that's that's really perfect
for you know in terms of chronological
cohesion in the in the narrative but
yeah I loved I loved that stuff I love
that stone
question right over here yes
early on you spoke to the warning sent
to the public about the that there could
be an issue with the u-boats where the
the willingness of the passengers to go
was it based on they're ignorant of the
danger ahead or was there just so much I
guess my question is how many voyages
were there happening daily weekly that
they just thought this can't happen to
me well you know I again you have to put
yourself back in the point of view of
the era very important and look at the
the whole thing through the eyes of
those who are going to get on the ship
that day I don't know exactly how many
people actually saw the the saw the the
morning I think I think it's pretty
obvious that quite a few did but they
saw it in the context of okay here is
this great ship
said to be so fast known to be so fast
and said to be faster than any any
submarine and in fact if it were to do
its top speed it would be far faster
than any submarine especially any
submarine that was submerged so there
was that this belief that it was too
fast too big to ever get caught by
submarine in fact cue nard said as much
an official announcement after the
departure in responding to the to the
German notice it was also the case that
from what I was able to tell it was
pretty clear that cue nard believed and
the passengers believed that the Royal
Navy would be looking out for them once
they got to the Irish Sea so there were
there was that but there was another
component which is the rules of maritime
warfare the rules of naval warfare
against civilian vessels for the prior
century essentially had forbidden
attacks against passenger liners and had
forbidden belligerent ships from from
sinking merchant ships without warning
and if they did sink a merchant ship
they had to make sure that the crew was
safe they had to bring them aboard or
even bring the merchant ship into a port
and then you know release all its crew
and so forth and and there a prize court
would determine the fate of the ship
these were the rules was very warfare
against civilian vessels was very
closely orchestrated things were
changing and nobody realized quite how
much at this point there were only sort
of glimmers that Germany had changed the
rules the Lusitania proved that of
course beyond a shadow of a doubt Eric
have a couple more questions sure I know
you have to sign a lot of books too and
then you have to have a torpedo with me
out in the lobby so you got it I think
that might be why I kept saying tornado
but that's another story there yeah this
is Terrence who had many many questions
ahead of the show maybe you have the
craft beer I drank but so what I love
about your work is that number one you
use source documents and number two is
that you bring the past to life I mean
today it seems like we just missed the
past and you bring history alive you
make it alive for all of us I love that
about you so but the question I have is
about how you choose your topics so you
seem to be on this thread right now
right the thread and you seem to
converge these disparate topics you know
whether it's marconi and murder in
London or devil in the White City so I'm
just interested in the process that you
go through and really pick up
pinpointing a topic to pursue the
research and then how you begin to bring
that into a narrative form and anybody
who works the thread into their next
question gets a drink out of way to go
Karen
well you know so so essentially like
like how how do how do I come up with
these ideas and you know first of all
the whole duel narrative thing I mean
I've been I've been people have sort of
interpreted my work to suggest for that
I've got this thing about making sure
that I have a dual narrative in all my
all my books and I share it's not an
intention of mine to do so
I don't have a stick although it may
seem that way yeah like in the garden
the beasts I mean the whole thing was
very organic
you had Nazis you've got you know the
Americans and they have to be there it's
not like a dual thing standing with
Lusitania got a submarine you got you
know it's it's what it is
but the idea process for me is is a
horrible phase it really is it's it's
it's very difficult I feel very
unproductive
it's what a friend of mine has coined a
term for she says that's when I'm in the
dark country of no ideas and it's so
true and you know the thing is to write
the kind of history that I like to write
which people have labeled narrative
nonfiction and I guess that's as good a
label as
anything the underlying idea has to have
certain qualities or you just can't you
can't do it because you can't fake it
you can't whatever so an idea has to be
it has to be interesting to me of course
it has to have a very rich archival base
so that I have I can find all the little
bits and pieces that will like the
reader's imagination it has to have a
built in organic narrative arc or engine
that is to say something that inherently
powers it along in the case of Lusitania
is begin on on May 1 under threat and
then you know the climax is on May 7 is
a natural narrative arc we look for
something like that so that you can
retell the story as a nonfiction work
but tell it at the beginning a middle
and an end and I also look for an idea
ideally not in this case not in the case
of Lusitania but typically I look for
barriers to entry which comes to the
sort of a dual narrative thing I mean
it's not again I don't look for dual
narratives but I like it if I find
something like the Krypton Marconi story
because I'm pretty confident nobody else
is going to do that look I hate
competition you know and the devil no I
said he was sort of the same way
although even there that came up is very
much an organic process so and to me
actually it is very much I like looking
for a spouse you know well you like you
know you women know this really a lot
better movie than the mend and that is
that you got to kiss a lot of frogs
right it a kiss a lot of frogs before
one kisses back in a not creepy way I
know what I mean I have three daughters
you know what I mean so so that's that's
the that's essentially the process are
you right now in the dark country of no
ideas thank you yes
how's that working for you that's a
question over there and then one last
one right here
I miss does have a lot of bullets over
but just for sharing tonight about dead
awake I can't help but connected to even
as recently this last week this
Germanwings flight that went down very
similar situation so sad and yet it as
mediate consumers we have to come up
this with a critical eye and how better
to learn them from someone who has
practiced historical method in such a
lively way just from your perspective
how did writing dead wake impact the way
that you view events like that that
happened the newspaper this week is such
an interesting question it it has cut
and vague ways has shaped my how I came
to the that whole shocking story about
this Germanwings flight but I'd be hard
to I'd be hard to quantify hard to
quantify it exactly although I can tell
you that I am I'm a deeply paranoid
flyer I hate to fly and I supposed to
hate to fly these little regional jets
you know and that story of that flight
has haunted me this week in I mean I'm
having to fly from place to place the
whole week it's like I didn't want to
talk about I mean it's such a it's such
a horrible horrible story and and it got
worse today you know what the news about
this guy that that his I guess it's
shrink or somebody had had sent him a
letter some medical entity at Senate a
letter saying that he was unfit to work
and you know he'd slashed this letter
and stuff and then he gets on the plane
and that's what happens you know it's
not hard do you think your your paranoia
about flying is about control or
what do you think it is what do we this
is a shrink session yep is this like
it's just like dr. feel it is it's just
like I'm waiting for somebody to come
out now and mouth that's all right I
don't know it I think it's you know it
is that at 6:00 - and I tend to work
claustrophobia and if you put me in a
seat that's meant for you know for my
dog I mean you know it it's hard that
makes total sense it does yeah last
question right here yes yes I'm if
you've got a very distinctive writing
style besides the kind of dual narrative
piece I was find your books are very
fast to read because I can't end a
paragraph without starting the next one
because of the foreshadow when you use
and some curious ones laughing and they
agree with me so kind of pulling on that
the thread of how you come to the board
okay you are okay can you comment how
you Mississippi how you learn to write
where'd you where'd you get the style
from I don't know
no don't so first of all thank you so
much for saying that about that they
read quickly in the foreshadowing and so
forth because that's the thing that I
really work very hard at in structuring
structuring my books and spent a lot of
time trying to make sure using well I
don't fictionalize anything I use the
techniques that novelists use which you
know foreshadowing withholding that kind
of thing to to keep the reader
interested to keep the story moving
along but you know if I had to if I had
to attribute learning learning to write
I'm obviously it's an evolutionary thing
but really one of the most powerful
things influences a reading and the
people like I've read in tend to be and
people I consider influences on my
writing are those who tend to emphasize
clean spare prose and that would be
Hemingway I mean Hemingway I know he's
lost a lot of cachet because maybe he's
kind of a jerk
maybe not I don't know although the
depiction in midnight in math when Paris
was lovely you know anyway because
because and I think that in particular
having with short stories the collection
in our time with so-called nickadams and
stories are particularly good examples
of clean spare prose and the art of not
saying like one of the best short
stories I think I think in my view the
best short story the short story called
Hills like white elephants that have
anyway I don't know how many of you know
that story but you read that story and
you know by the time you're done with it
so you know exactly what's going on but
he never tells you as hard as that is to
grasp never he never says it directly it
just you just you come to it and that's
that's absolutely that's a genius so so
Hemingway you know Hammett Chandler
Steinbeck Fitzgerald - to an extent
these are my my my influences but in a
practical level it was really my
experience I worked for for quite a bit
at at The Wall Street Journal I got
extremely lucky after my first mr. burr
job went to the Wall Street Journal had
time when feature writing was the thing
that was emphasized and writing as well
they didn't want people in your business
they wanted people who could write
figuring you could learn business and so
I had to do these so I'd so I've not had
to I mean I loved these these stories
writing these things it was an exercise
all the time and trying to get as much
into this thing in a compelling way and
and paring it down to the absolute
absolute minimum of what you need to get
the story across and that was really
really tremendously valuable but
otherwise I just have to say it's
evolutionary you know but thank you for
for commenting on that thank you very
much for coming thank you
[Music]
eris will be signing books I'll be in
the lobby and I owe to people drink for
the threads way to go thank you
[Music]